c'est à toi thierry qui l'a acheté en
faisant un don à l'association laurette
fugain
ah oui c'est vrai il a téléphoné il m'a
dit est ce que je peux investir mille
euros pour toi à la vente aux enchères
de l'association laurette fugain et ce
qui me rapporte pour 1000 euros
ebay ca vaut plus que ça la chambre
c'est le costume de scène de michel
sardou le costume de scène de michel
sardou
c'est sûr que c'est le sien quand on
voit la taille des jambes ya pas de
doute c'est un certificat d'authenticité
salvador at-elle chapeau d'henri
salvador
je suis très fier et j'ai vendu mes
clefs de bagnole à claude berri comme
quoi il a parmi les bons français ça
alors on fait le tour des ventes aux
enchères mais comme il n'a pas trop de
blé évidemment c'est ses potes qui paye
aussi qu'est ce que tu veux que je fous
du costume de scène je veux que tu
mettes l'adresse de l'association
laurette fugain emballé s'il vous plaît
monsieur galfond voilà et que tu met ça
en vente au profit de l'association
laurette fugain la carte donc je le
revends moi je l'achète 1000 euros et il
va john d sardo donc si vous voulez
acheter pour ton bien
bon le mécontement aux enchères on le
met aux enchères
voilà le costume de scène de michel
sardou ça devrait faire dans les dix
mille saint louis à wayne ont bien je
vais le garder comme ça toute la soirée
je sais bien que c'est bien
et ben non